[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une chauffe eau stationné leur est
d'ailleurs mon objectif mais neuf
minutes que j'ai avec vous c'est de
partager
comment vous pouvez peut-être réussir à
embarquer une petite recette pour être
aussi impactant aussi puissant aussi
énergétique dans votre quotidien pour
faire en sorte qu'ils chauffent comme
élire demain comme élire un seul comme
épaule tient c'est une personne qui vaut
le coup c'est une personne qui a agi sur
quelque chose d'important à mes yeux
donc c'est vraiment le sens de mon
intervention qui a poussé m
aliens in german tedx culte waouh je
connais je me faisais donc aux larmes
communauté de tedx ils sont tellement
forts ils ont écouté tellement de
personnes jeunes ou john lydon et
finalement le bon tiens ça peut être
intéressante de leur donner un petit
outil une petite manière de faire un
mécanisme que j'ai déjà rodé pour que
vos mazel
il contribue je suis sûr que vous êtes
tous en train de contribuer à faire
plein de choses mais d'avoir une
démarche structurée je suis ingénieur
donc s'épargner mouvement balle schafier
fériés dues aux filles et aux fils ma
manière de faire donc je vais essayer de
partager avec vous justement cette cette
manière de faire
d'abord pour qu'on puisse trouver toute
l'énergie nécessaire pour faire des
choses fortes et puissantes et
impactante il faut que ça a du sens pour
nous donc il faut d'abord se poser la
question pourquoi on est là qu est ce
qui nous fait plaisir une fois une
touche non labour à collo aline
qu'est-ce que qui est important à nos
yeux pourquoi la vie est belle donc
toute cette quasi tous ces questions il
ya en général non ce n'est pas faute qu
il est en général on agit on vivre
on subit des pressions réagi par rapport
à des pressions mais on se passe on se
pose pas forcément pour se dire tiens
pourquoi c'est important pour moi de
faire ça pourquoi ça a du sens pour moi
de faire telle ou telle action
j'ai voulu insister sur un petit point
c'est que à chaque étape de notre vie à
chaque tranche de notre vie il ya des
choses importantes et des choses moins
importante et il faut pouvoir se poser à
chaque à chaque étape importante
qu'est ce qui est important pour nous et
ça c'est pas toujours évident de le
saisir sa rate on considère qu'à 20 ans
et à quand on aux enjeux sont toujours
les mêmes à 40 ans et soixante dix ans
nos enjeux sont toujours les mêmes mais
non il faut prendre conscience que nos
enjeux sont différents en fonction de la
période
et ça c'est vraiment un exercice
important est nommé ça donne ce qui est
important pour moi c'est dans cette
toute évolution ébullition tunisienne
dans toute cette transformation
économique démocratique sociale c'est de
contribuer modestement à faire quelque
chose à partager mon expérience à réagir
sur des choses ça n'avance pas forcément
à la bonne vitesse de la bonne manière
mais je me sens utile de contribuer à
justement cette transformation cette
effervescence que nous vivions en
tunisie donc vraiment c'est important de
comprendre pourquoi on est là pour quoi
on va être là et pour et sur contre on
veut agir une fois qu'on a ça on va se
dire voilà win a besoin seul où est ce
qu'on veut faire pousser les limites
verbe faire bouger les limites genou à
la vision que je veux porter et comment
arriver à voir grand comment ne pas être
par des freins souvent quand on
essaye de se projeter on se dit ah ça va
être difficile pour un starter il va
dire je vais pas trouver les
financements par un chef d'entreprise il
fait il va dire je vais pas te trouver
des ressources donc justement comment se
se libérer de ses de ses contraintes et
être vraiment dans une vision
complètement ouverte complètement en qui
nous emporte et qui nous permet d'aller
plus loin
on a eu l'occasion j'ai eu l'occasion
d'accompagner il ya quelques années un
chef d'entreprise les lots et qui gère
pas le jeu et menons bout société aidez
nous à transformer un développer mon
entreprise il a exprimé d'une manière où
j'ai 100 collaborateurs je veux passer à
150 collaborateurs en trois ans et des
mois à faire
finalement me travaille un peu avec lui
il a pris conscience qu'il était capable
d'aller plus loin et en quatre ans il
est passé à 500 collaborateurs
il est passé à une entreprise leader en
tunisie une référence sur l'afrique et
avec un rayonnement et avec une ambition
encore plus importante sur les
prochaines années
donc c'est vraiment important quand on
se projette quand on se donne des
objectifs quand on veut être impactant
de ne pas se freiner par on va dire les
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer et ça
c'est vraiment important dans la proche
et dans la démarche
deuxième élément qui est clé et ça
souvent l'oublier c'est notre pouvoir
faire changer les choses il souvent
j'aime bien cette image où on peut se
voir comme on est on peut se voir
beaucoup moins quand ce qu'on est et on
peut se voir beaucoup plus que ce qu'on
est
c'est important de justement de déjà
d'être bien dans ses baskets de bien
comprendre ce qu'on est capable de faire
d'être aussi entouré par des gens qui
vous encouragent les gens qui vous aide
à prendre conscience de votre manière de
de votre pouvoir à faire changer les
choses
des gens qui sont pas au quotidien en
train de vous casser en train de vous
démoraliser en train de vous de vous
présenter toutes les lacunes qui peuvent
exister ça c'est vraiment important à la
rate alors plus on est poussé plus on
est plus on est challengé plus on va
donner de nous mêmes et souvent pour
nous mêmes et pour les autres magnin
souvent on oublie qu'on est aussi en
mesure d'aider beaucoup d'autres et ça
cette avarie qu'on a parfois à aider les
autres il faut en prendre conscience
parfois même un ouvrier contre lui
sourit le matin il est ravi vous avez
gagné votre sa vie donc ayez conscience
de votre vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui
est un petit problème et vous avez
rencontré un problème similaire
n'hésitez pas à l'aider n'hésitez pas à
partager ça avec lui
ces éléments ne sont pas toujours
faciles à partager parce qu'on se dit
peut-être qu'on n'a pas la légitimité
peut être qu'on n'a pas la crédibilité
mais osé parce que ça peut aider
beaucoup d'autres une fois qu'on éclaire
sur ça j'ai voulu partager avec vous
quelques accélérateur quelques
accélérateur qui vont vous aider à on va
dire à faire plein d'impact j'en ai
rodez pas mal et donc c'est pour ça que
je suis à l'aise pour en parler d'abord
créer l'urgence si une action nécessite
deux jours pour une semaine pour qu'elle
soit faite et que vous prenez un mois
perdez votre temps donc le choc le csaj
dans lequel vous êtes embarqué n'est pas
le bon ou vous considérez que vous êtes
immortel et donc vous tromper
complètement
prenez conscience que le temps c'est
important et donc si quelque chose si
c'est quelque chose qui est victime
importante pour vous qui est passionnant
pour vous qui est qui sur laquelle vous
voulez agir créer cette urgence créer ce
cette dynamique positive qui va vous
permettre justement de de puiser
énormément d'énergie et d'être dans
l'action dans l'action efficace et dans
l'action impactante cette urgence est
importante mais pour vous mais aussi
elle est importante pour les autres qui
sont avec vous pour que vous avancez
dans le même et tout élément important
c'est de prendre conscience qu'on ne
peut pas réaliser des choses importantes
si on échoue donc le travail d'équipé
clés dont cnam l'alabama brown
s'entraider bâtir avec les autres est
aussi un élément important
moi j'adore écouter oussama mallouli
quand il travaille quand il parle du
travail d'équipé c'est passionnant on a
l'impression de l'extérieur que le spoil
la nage est un sport individuel alors
qu'il vous explique si la passe toute
son équipe de médecins de deux
entraîneurs de tout le staff qui vont
porter un leader ça marche pas et ça
fait cette dynamique de groupe est
importante et que tout le groupe soit
dans le même rythme dans la même
ambition dans la même accélération dans
la même vitesse est aussi un élément
pourtant donc si vous êtes dans une
équipe si vous êtes dans un
environnement où vous voulez être à une
vitesse de 100 à l'heure et les
autrichiens 10 à l'heure vous n'êtes pas
au bon endroit
donc là aussi c'est des choses c'est des
petites choses que que j'ai rodez je
voulu partager avec vous parce que
parfois on s'épuise à essayer de de
tirer avec nous d'autres personnes
d'autres d'autres contributeurs et
finalement on n'arrive pas à les
intéresser on n'arrive pas à les
embarquer rapidement autre élément
important c'est vraiment de d'avoir des
étapes et de célébrer ses victoires là
c'est pas toujours évident on est
souvent obsédé par par l'objectif final
et on oublie justement ces étapes
intermédiaires on oublie de se dire ah
tiens on a franchi une première étape et
c'est bien faisons nous plaisir
célébrons cette première étape
je vois par exemple là on a eu les
élections des élections municipales
presque le jour même beaucoup de
critiques beaucoup de beaucoup de
beaucoup de remarques plutôt négatif
c'est d'un processus fin passé dans un
pays où on avait pas d'élection un pays
où on a des élections première deuxième
troisième
je participe à chaque fois où avec l'isi
c'est passionnant le
le visage des gens qui viennent voter
c'est juste passionnant prenons un peu
le temps de d'apprécier ces étapes c'est
ses premières victoires ces victoires
intermédiaires qui sont importantes
dernier élément c'est justement la
persévérance
souvent on est confronté à beaucoup de
difficultés et c'est normal si on n'est
pas persévérant si on n'est pas dedans
je vais y arriver je vais y arriver et
qu'on n'a pas autour de soi des gens qui
nous aident justement sur ça on va très
très vite lâché donc cette persévérance
et clé moi j'ai quand j'ai commencé le
conseil j'avais 30 ans en tunisie
je devais conseillers des chefs
d'entreprise des banquiers un revoir
leurs processus de crédit gens me
disaient qu'est ce que tu fais tu y
arriveras pas
j'étais convaincu que je pouvais
apporter quelque chose c'était soutenu
par mon entourage et j'ai eu des
menteurs qui m'ont aidé dans ma vie
professionnelle et donc ça m'a permis de
me bouthillier et d'être encore plus
persévérante et de maintenir le cap
donc vraiment c'est vraiment trois
petits accélérateur que ce soit être
être sur l'urgence soi même et puis les
autres êtres sur les victoires
intermédiaires et être dans la
persévérance
ça va vous permettre de justement bâtir
les gravir les échelons bâtir les étapes
intermédiaires pour atteindre justement
votre impact les sujets les les enjeux
les chalands sur lequel vous voulez vous
engager vous voulez engager avec vous
des gens pour justement atteindre et
faire bouger les lignes quel que soit le
sujet qui soit un sujet économique qui
soit un sujet social qu'elle soit une
cause juste juste une cause qui peut
nous aider
j'ai voulu vraiment terminée par par
cette image pourquoi parce que on donne
en 200 ans en donnant de son énergie
pour les autres certes vous donner
beaucoup pour les autres mais surtout
vous vous faites plaisir et plus vous en
donner plus vous en recevez donc soyez
vraiment dans cette logique de d'impact
de faire bouger les lignes
parce que le retour est là et la
satisfaction et le bonheur que vous
allez avoir n'a vraiment pas de prix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]